this program is brought to you by Emory
University gas prices were really high
and that definitely pushes down consumer
spending and and gives a lot of firms a
cause to be cautious about their hiring
several firms big firms are entering
their fiscal year and I think that that
has a lot to do with their hiring
decisions people who had been previously
out of the labor force are likely to
enter back into the labor force as the
economy gets moving and when you see
that you can actually see the
unemployment rate tick up it's very very
common I think that with graduations a
lot of students entered into the
workforce and didn't have jobs and you
tend to see unemployment rate took up
when that happens as well no I actually
don't think it'll be a long-term trend I
think we're going to see tick up this
month and I think it's going to stay
constant but it's going to be decreasing
throughout the rest of the summer and I
think it we're going to start seeing so
much lower unemployment rates as we get
into early fall I think that we're
moving in the right direction even
though we unemployment rate he's ticked
up a little bit the overall trend has
been a downward trend and people get way
too wrapped up in looking at one
particular month rather than the overall
trend or what was happening during that
month our economy has been growing our
economy has actually been doing very
well we have had very nagging and high
unemployment but I think that one of the
reasons for that has been firms have
been able to be profitable while running
very lean and they haven't had a need to
hire workers and I still think that
they're substituting technology for
labor and so even though the economy is
strong unemployment is going to stay
high if you look at other indicators of
economic growth things like changes in
the real GDP profitability of major
companies the ability of our car
manufacturers to pay back their loans
that all of those point to a very strong
and robust economy yeah I think it's
more positive than negative I think that
we have shown that some industries are
based in in the united states have been
profitable have actually worked to put
together a good business model and are
actually moving in that too
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University